a
21st century mine no elevator shafts
no pickaxes just
stacks and stacks of whirring computers
they're overheating circuit boards
naturally cooled by the chilly canadian
air
bit farms is a cryptocurrency mining
company
it has five of these sites in quebec its
president
jeffrey morphy says their machines
recently crossed a mind-boggling
milestone we are currently uh
generating over 1x a hash of production
one exahash exa being a one
followed by 18 zeros the number of
calculations they make
every second all searching for the next
hash number the first miner to find it
gets rewarded with
six and a quarter fresh bitcoins quebec
has quickly become a global hub for the
crypto mining industry
with around 80 companies now based in
the province
all fanned by the dizzying rise in the
price of bitcoin
as bitcoin prices started up in october
of last year
uh from 10 000 to 12 000 to 15
to 20 000 us dollars per bitcoin
we were ecstatic and then when it moved
through 30 and moved through 40 and
moved through 50
the margins just got stronger and
stronger
this modern virtual gold rush is all
made possible by what is known as
blockchain technology and how it
organizes
and secures transaction data
unlike a conventional database a
blockchain is replicated on
all users computers across a distributed
network a series of encrypted data
blocks
are arranged in a sequential chain a
blockchain
a new block of data containing new
transactions is added to the end of the
chain
every 10 minutes or so just like new
lines on a ledger
for security you can't change the old
blocks you can only add
new ones and even more importantly when
any bitcoin gets bought and sold
the data must be replicated on the
majority of the network
that helps to prevent hacking and fraud
miners verify the ever more complex
history of transactions
and get rewarded with new bitcoins
it's a pure bubble right it has no
intrinsic value
there i personally think bitcoin is a
long-term hedge
if you really understand bitcoin
just like the alberta oil sands the
market value of what you're digging for
must outweigh the cost of mining it
morphy says it currently costs them more
than
seven thousand bucks to mine one coin
but there's a finite number of bitcoins
left to mine
and over time the system makes them more
and more difficult
to find a recent estimate says the
industry worldwide uses as much energy
as sweden a cambridge university study
found that more than half of the mining
is powered by fossil fuels morphy says
that is why quebec with its low-cost
hydro power
makes greener sense our input in terms
of electricity our
largest input is done with renewable
energy
and then our output being heat we're
looking for
value chain opportunities there where we
can actually sell
or use our heat as a byproduct for other
businesses
one idea in the works is to invite a
tomato greenhouse farm to set up right
beside
the bitcoin farm but for now all that
bitcoin
heat is going unused
the growing field of blockchain is about
much more
than cryptocurrency just ask alex
tapscott
co-author of the book blockchain
revolution so what blockchain basically
enables is digital scarcity a way to
move
a unique digital asset over the internet
peer-to-peer to somebody else without
the need for
a traditional third party like a bank or
a government and that might seem like a
simple innovation but it's profound
profound because the system by its
design will
securely and automatically verify a
transaction
or contract you could theoretically
write a will or buy a house without a
lawyer land title registries are very
antiquated
mostly paper-based by moving them all
into a blockchain we could
have certainty that when you're buying a
home you know that the
occupant is the owner right put the
deposit money into you know
a digital escrow inside of a smart
contract
wait for the conditions of the
transaction to clear
at which point the transaction would
become irrevocable just written in code
how about an election without an army of
officials
you know vote is an asset you uh when
you vote once you
you want to make sure you can't vote
again and so it's useful even for
uh democracy and other government
applications
there are different types of blockchains
for different uses
one of the most popular being ethereum
co-founded by russian canadian vitalik
buterin
ethereum supports smart contracts and
the
ether currency for those who want to
trade in cryptocurrencies but don't want
the risk there are so called stable
coins
usually pegged to the u.s dollar
something that could benefit people
in developing nations you don't have
access to a bank account your local
currency is being inflated away you've
got to deal with the corrupt government
this is a godsend and we're starting to
see it get picked up
quite strongly in those parts of the
world despite the energy being used to
mine cryptocurrencies
this technology could actually be put to
work in tackling
climate change
pedro bis is the head of research at the
blockchain and
climate institute a think tank set up to
help governments and organizations
harness the power of blockchain we look
at the
financial sector as a whole and of the
green or sustainable financial products
by far green bonds stand out from the
crowd
and it could be one of those financial
instruments that really helps to
mobilize the
trillions of dollars that we need to
tackle to help tackle climate change
bis says blockchain could make green
bonds far more efficient and most
importantly
transparent for example satellites could
be used to track
tree planting efforts the bond buyer and
seller could instantly see the specific
trees they've planted and the current
size of the carbon offset
without the need for expensive site
surveys
it could encourage even the smallest of
farmers to get involved
really what we need is not just this tax
or or or labels of green what we need is
impact
what we need is measurable action that
we say oh yeah we remove this amount of
co2
we remove this amount of you know
energy consumption
a pilot project in ecuador sells
chocolate bars online
a blockchain token in the wrapper lets
you help farmers plant a new cocoa tree
which you can then track online
another green benefit of blockchain
could be making power grids
more efficient where anyone with a solar
panel could become a
prosumer selling energy not just to the
utility
but to anyone else on the grid
data is fundamental for this transition
and that's why you know there's been
this rollout for smart meters you know
and it's amazing how people to
understand that with our smart meters we
are not going to get a smart grid
and without a smart grid we are not
going to get a green you know
sustainable grid
i got solar panels because i had all
this roof space we have all the sun
i mean look at this this is fabulous
the aptly named daniel power joined the
brooklyn microgrid
pilot project hoping his bookstore could
go green
and so i will buy from my neighbors and
that are
prosumers i might buy for myself i don't
know
but regulation has lagged behind the
technology
and three years on the pandemic has
stalled the rollout
for now but after the approval from
the utilities commission to take it a
step further
nothing never happened that's when kobet
hit another small idea to plant
cedar trees in lebanon got cut down when
the lebanese economy collapsed
but tapscott believes these growing
pains are to be expected
and can be overcome if decision-makers
wrap their heads around
the complexities but also government
could be a model user of this technology
a lot of the best applications of
blockchain for example central bank
digital currencies
um you know digital health records land
titles and so forth
are things that the government could
benefit a lot from embracing so
um i'm pretty optimistic i've been
pretty pleased with what i've seen so
far and
i certainly hope it continues
blockchain's potential is huge
the biggest hurdle to it being realized
could be how hard it is
to grasp but then again how many of us
know what goes on under the hood of our
car
or inside our smartphone